hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime out Pro and today I will
be talking about the absolute craziness
of the current black over Total War Ark
including the incredible transformation
of the demon king Dante Austin's new
demon form and a tragic twist that might
signal the untimely end of an important
supporting character in the story in
case you guys are wondering I didn't get
a black lower video out last week not
because I didn't want to but due to some
important family obligations
this whole current arc in the story is
just incredible and trust me I will make
videos on it whenever I can there is so
much to talk about so let's get into it
if you enjoyed the black clover content
on this channel you want us to keep it
go and please leave a like to let me
know it really does help and if you have
it to be new to anime uproar or you just
haven't subscribed yet please don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications I'm big thank you to all
of our anime our patrons who make videos
like this one possible with YouTube the
way it is right now patron support is
more important than ever thank you guys
so much I'll talk more about patreon at
the end of the video but for now please
be advised that this video will contain
black cover manga spoilers I'm breaking
down the very latest developments in the
story so please proceed with caution you
have been warned the battle between
Dante and hasta began back in chapter
241 with Dante using his demon king
gravity magic and hasta countering with
his newly improved post time-skip anti
magic at first
hasta is able to keep up with Dante's
magic because he has the help of
Vanessa's red thread of fate which as we
know defies the laws of nature and is in
itself an unbelievably overpowered spell
but Dante is able to figure out what's
happening pretty quickly and he storms
the black bull's base with the intention
of putting a stop to Vanessa's
shenanigans the black bull's can't
believe the power and range of Dante's
magic and he seems all but unstoppable
however instead of taking out Vanessa in
order to prevent her from interfering
with his plans dante tells vanessa that
he is impressed with her magic and her
Beauty and her figure then he proceeds
to ask her to be his woman okay let's
back it up for a second yes Dante is an
evil mastermind who uses demon power to
subjugate the people of his own Kingdom
and to wage wars on other kingdoms but
damn clearly he is also a man of culture
I might not agree with his actions but I
do agree with the man's impeccable taste
Vanessa is a top tier magical waifu
after dante reveals himself to be a
member of the dark triad auste is more
determined than ever to take him on and
he attacks dante yet again using anti
magic dante is surprised that there is
someone possessed by a demon inside the
clover kingdom but as hard as hasta is
trying to get a hit on Dante by using
every attack in his arsenal Dante is
able to easily dodge all of us as
assaults since Isis attacks can't seem
to land on their own Austin gauche come
up with a brilliant plan gauche uses his
mirror magic to reflect Oscars attacks
which multiplies the attacks many times
over this creates a combo magic attack
called mirror meteorites and even Dante
looks a bit shook up when he faces the
prospect of all of these anti magic
attacks flying at him all at once but
just when the black bull's think that
Dante might be in trouble he raises his
demon power up to 50% and his body
transforms he grows to black demon horns
on his head and he also grows black
wings on his back this new and improved
Dante is then somehow able to use his
gravity magic to distort the space
around him in order to avoid Oscars
attack to austin Ghosh's complete
surprise I'm just gonna say it Dante is
no logical from boku no hero his gravity
powers are actually really impressive
and who knows what other abilities he
has in his arsenal I can't wait to find
out no offense Ochoco but you have a
long way to go
dante says that although there is a
difference in rank hasta is using the
same type of demonic possession as the
dark triad i assumed that when he says
rank dante is referring to the rank of
the demons themselves
Dante's demon must be a
ranked Diamond Anastas just like the
kotodama diamond was but asta says that
he is nothing like the dark triad
because they are evil and they oppress
their own people and yet the ever
cheerful Dante just takes Oscars comment
as a compliment according to Dante
calling him evil is a compliment because
evil intention is what distinguishes
humans from animals unlike all other
animals humans are capable of things
like hatred vengeance destruction and
evil intention and that is what makes
humans unique evil is humanity's true
nature and you can never be fully human
until you embrace and release those
negative emotions we can assume that
Dante's willingness to fully embrace
hatred evil and negative emotions is
what allows him to use so much of his
demons power the demon feeds on these
types of emotions and this makes him
stronger
austan the other hand does his best to
control his emotions with his strong and
Noble heart even at times when he is
experiencing anger hatred and negativity
dante clearly has the upper hand on
hasta at this point and he is literally
stomping down on hasta as they talk
vanessa tries to use the red thread of
fate to help hasta
but dante turns to her and tells her
that she is his woman and she shouldn't
be using her magic to help another man
what a gentleman
our boy dante is top tier Waman
respecter dante then raises his demon
power to 60% and he uses his gravity
magic to disperse rouge the cat suddenly
all of a neces mana is gone and Henri
says that soon the monarch wired to move
the mecha headquarters will be depleted
as well Dante then uses his demon King
gravity magic to pin Vanessa gauche and
grey against the wall forcing them to
stay still dante proceeds to summon a
massive sword and as he tells hasta that
he intends to awaken asked us true
emotions dante pierces goes straight
through the torso with the massive sword
the black bulls are in shock over what
just happened to gosh and just as dante
predicted the emotions explode within
hasta and he attains a brand new demon
form
this new form more of Asta's body is
consumed by the demonic darkness his
right hand and foot have become dark
claws and it almost looks like he has
grown two extra horns on the top of his
head although that might just be his
hair it's hard to tell by the dark
shading in that specific panel all in
all I've been saying for a while now
that this war arc is frickin epic and
this chapter just drives that point home
so hard
by all indications ghosts should be dead
from that wound an injury so severe from
a sword so big would kill anyone sure
this is a series about magic so maybe
this is just a troll like with the you
know thing a few chapters ago and gauche
will somehow survive but as things stand
right now Ghosh looks poised to become
the first black bull member to die this
is a major major development and Asta's
new demon form which is a direct result
of hasta witnessing what just happened
the gauche is bound to be a game-changer
I don't think that hasta will be
stronger than Dante even in this new
form but hasta may now be strong enough
to keep Dante busy until Yami arrives
and then with Yami's help hasta and the
black balls may be somehow able to push
Dante back I honestly can't believe what
just happened such epic new demon forms
have been revealed both for Dante and
for hasta and in general the dark triad
possesses such interesting and
overpowered magic this has been an
amazing arc so far and it just keeps
getting better with that said it's
definitely sad that we now may have the
first black bull death in the series at
first I thought that maybe this ghost
that got stabbed was a mirror clone that
goes created with his spell real double
what the clone that real double creates
is a mirror image of the original and
this gauche has the same features as the
original he is not a mirror image so
either this is the real gauche or maybe
he somehow learned to boost his real
double spell in order to create multiple
clones and this double is actually a
mirror image of a mirror image I know it
sounds confusing and I'm sure we will
find out in the next chapter but for now
we have to accept the very real
possibility that goes might be dead
and I hate to say this but as sad as
Ghosh's death would be I'm really glad
that Dante likes Vanessa and that he
didn't kill her
my editor Dakota broski and I were both
afraid that Vanessa would be the one to
die during this battle which would be my
nightmare since I love Vanessa so much
and speaking of my editor Dakota broski
he is not only a huge black lower fan
like me even though he loves Noelle when
one essay is clearly best girl and even
dante agrees with me bro accept it but
dakota is also pretty much the most
interesting man in the world he has his
own anime youtube channel he is a
professional bartender he goes on random
cross-country road trips and he performs
as a singer at various venues in fact he
has no idea that I'm going to ask him to
do this but here is Dakota singing a
Frank Sinatra cover of black Rover
well sorry on the Mac if it's cringy as
cringe if it's not it's not but you
asked for it
Oh get down we all let you know this
time can you bring me down back up it's
fall from the sky black Rover get down
we all let you know this time can you
bring me down back up back up from the
sky black Rover black
Rover
[Music]
to all your weaves definitely check out
the Coda's youtube channel and show the
man some love link in the description
also please give me your impressions of
the dante versus hasta fight so far are
you impressed with Austin's new form and
how strong do you think the new and
improved hasta will be and what about
Dante's epic demon king magic how strong
this guy possibly be at full power
he is definitely immensely powerful and
we all expected that but what I didn't
expect is that Dante is also a true man
of culture mad respect for that finally
do you think that a ghost could really
be dead or are we going to get another
you know style fake-out let me know down
in the comments below if you enjoyed
this video you want to see more black
lower content please leave a like to let
me know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar or you just haven't
subscribed yet please subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications the way the YouTube works
now if you don't take the time to hit
the bell and then select the option that
says all you're gonna miss a lot of our
videos
it's just how it goes you can also hit
me up on Twitter and/or Instagram at
anime uproar I want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime out patrons for
supporting our work and making these
videos possible with all the constant
problems on YouTube
patrons support is more important than
ever thank you guys so much
first and foremost a special thank you
to our the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including in
grata Alan Adam the world Steelers the
school bus Tyson Corina acquired respect
and Pat a heffa and I can't forget our
pro hero tier patrons including the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings Eldridge fitted ala
beat alpha do Anatoly Cassatt ski on
he'll Cruz team Sparky 65 cricket XP
Rohan Kapoor Jessica Maloney Emperor
otaku Timothy Eve Argus Sean dark Joe
Stanton jccc wakka Barry Gucci and
Jessica Kayla Fong
if you enjoy our videos and you think
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]